competitive valorent is changing forever
ride games announced that in 2023 the
vct be moving towards a franchised model
featuring international and regional
leagues some people love the changes
others aren't so sure here are the
details so you can decide for yourself
[Music]
hey everyone it's elizabeth i'm still
recovering from covid as you can tell
and here but this news was too big not
to share but don't forget to like
subscribe and hit the notification bell
just all of the things and as danny says
cheers if you've watched valerian's
competitive scene at least for a little
bit by now you're used to how things
work it is routine qualify to compete in
your region get those circuit points
work to compete on the international
stage and then do it all over again well
get rid of those usual expectations
homie crush him throw him out because
the future of competitive valorant is
here well it's coming in 2023 so it's
right around the corner on april 28th
ryde announced how they would be
revamping the valor and competitive
scene with all new features and
infrastructure they summarized
everything in a handy-dandy pyramid
chart that breaks it all down the first
thing is that there will be an in-game
competitive mode that's separate from
the standard ranked queue this will help
you and your fellow cracked kids qualify
for domestic leagues which in riot's
words not mine will provide esports
organizations with a new way to recruit
you so remember us little ones when all
of you are up there competing on riot's
coolest stages with like your tsm or
face jersey okay moving on up the
pyramid let's talk about domestic
leagues these would be organized
competition spaces that will work
hand-in-hand with that new in-game mode
to help showcase your talents to the
world they've already done something
like this in europe we've seen vrl or
valerent regional leagues in europe with
leagues in france spain turkey cis and
other parts of emea then we reach game
changers riot plans to invest more into
game changers which includes quote more
training sessions for aspiring talent
third-party tournaments have always been
a thing we'll continue to be but then we
get to the gritty of international
leagues cue the dun dun dun but actually
pay attention to me and take us out of
1.25 speed for once and listen up pardon
me while i read directly from the source
quote international leagues will be our
new premier level week over week
competition in the valorant esports
ecosystem on land and in studios with
audiences health and safety permitting
across the globe these leagues will be
the new method by which teams qualify
for our premier level global tournaments
masters and champions i know you're
excited about in-person events something
our league siblings got to enjoy but
pipe down because there is more we'll
incorporate a long-term partnership
model with a select number of teams in
each league teams from north america
latin america and brazil will make up a
league teams from europe russia turkey
and mena that's middle east and north
africa and teams from southeast asia
korea japan south asia and oceania that
is a lot to take in so to break it down
liz spark notes style leagues are being
formed in each of these regions these
leagues are how teams will compete for
masters or champions events riot will
also select teams to wave their feeds
and provide funding quote in return for
their investment in the growing
ecosystem
which sounds very financed bro from
being honest to you but basically what
this means is that this differs from
normal franchising in normal franchising
teams would have to pay a lot of money
for their spot with this new format
though certain teams won't be charged
they only need to apply for a chance to
be selected which is precisely why you
have people like castro hoping that
they'll be selected by riot as a partner
at the tippy tippy top of the pyramid is
masters and champions as well as a game
changers championship there are plans
for bringing these events to a live
audience as soon as this year if
possible teams will compete from those
international leagues to make it here
via a selection process that has not
been detailed yet so this is all pretty
familiar and pretty vague our league
siblings are now like pointing at their
screen like leonardo dicaprio because
yes this is what ryde has learned with
league and they're now applying it to
valorant in 2018 wright moved to have
the nalcs be franchised with a 10
million dollar flat fee and a whole host
of steps for teams to become a part of a
league the reaction to the valorent
franchising from the community has been
pretty positive well besides vanity who
might become a fortnite pro if he has to
move to la which like fair anthony fair
la sucks but i'm from jersey i've been
raised to hate the west coast but there
has been some fear about the franchising
and what this will do to lower tier
teams and scenes franchising means that
we will not see those moments where
smaller teams will fight their way to
the top and fight the biggest dogs like
tsm versus discord kitties
anyone
fight of the century philip arum lscs
players association executive director
warned that if anything gets franchised
like this it's not actually good news
when any developer provides franchising
or long-term partnerships to select
teams they are effectively closing the
marketplace to competition these teams
gain unprecedented ability to say if you
don't like it good luck going to one of
those other fixed teams with power he
went on to describe how in league of
legends franchising reduces market
competition with no teams outside the
closed league to compete with or it can
offer the bare minimum to players simply
because they can we've also seen
franchising just play not do super well
like with the overwatch league or cod
where it is super expensive to own a
team and teams are just eventually sold
obviously this won't be the case here
with riot fronting the costs but
franchising isn't all sunshine and
rainbows you've also seen for a while
player concerns about how franchises
like the overwatch league just aren't
the right way to go about things
whatever you think about these changes
they are huge i feel like i just got
used to the whole challengers masters
champions at the ballerina champions
tour and then bam
whole new structure also rye if 2023
doesn't bring a clear nomenclature i
don't want it it also confuses effies
one of my favorite things about valerian
is just about how everyone is able to
compete and find their way how teams
like girl kissers can work their way
upward i fear franchising will take the
spotlights away from those tiers 2 and
tier 3 golden teams and plenty of
esports have done just fine without
franchising csgo is on franchise and
unbeaten as one of the top esports in
the world but franchising does have its
benefits to esports as a whole including
stability and monetary gain it is 2022
however so we'll have to wait a little
bit longer to see how all these changes
affect the scene hopefully all this
franchising will bring about the dawn of
an even greater valorem where anyone can
compete on the path to pro and be
scouted by these top teams and not just
grind ranked and pray that shazam says
on stream who is this kid sign him which
means all of you crack the zoomers can
get out of my ranked games and go
somewhere else
like the grandest stage of them all
wheeler yuda okay listen
i turned into like a five-year-old i
love wheeler yuda okay
he's so talented he's so cute that
moment where he like sat in the middle
of the ring and just like signed bcc on
his chest and blood i was like wheeler
wheeler